ravi de vous retrouver dans parlement
hebdo 45 minutes d'actualité politique
et parlementaire bonjour michaëlle jean
chrétien est la une cette semaine le
coup d'envoi du marathon budgétaire à
l'assemblée les députés ont entamé
l'examen des recettes le projet de loi
prévoit 3 milliards de hausse d'impôts
et 15 milliards d'économies
l'effort repose essentiellement sur les
ménages nous prendrons la direction de
marseille pour la primaire socialiste en
vue des élections municipales
ambiance pour le moins électrique entre
sam et gallier patrick l'outil pour le
débat d'entre deux tours accusations en
tous genres la réconciliation prendra
certainement un petit peu de temps et
puis il ya un an des marettes un long
bras de fer à notre dame des landes à
côté des crs mobilisés sur la zone de
construction du nouvel aéroport de
l'autre des opposants au projet qui
tienne bon un documentaire diffusé sur
notre antenne revient sur cette lutte
c'est le plus de parlement hebdo et pour
commenter toute cette actualité bonjour
barbara pompili genre député écologiste
de la somme coprésidente du groupe
écologiste à l'assemblée nationale
membre de la commission des affaires
culturelles et de l'éducation a un je
vous propose de regarder avec nous cette
petite image qu'on va vous proposer
c'était votre première intervention dans
l'hémicycle 24 juillet 2012 c'était de
questions d'actualité
plutôt sage peut-être un petit peu
impressionné alors un an et demi plus
tard on va voir ce que disent vos
confrères de vous si vous voulez bien
écouter investi engagé et en même temps
respectueuse percutante dans
dans ses interventions parfois un peu
éloigné des réalités
du terrain très certainement efficacité
calmer sens de la répartie assez
vindicative par moments ayant de
l'obstination et puis parfois excessives
voilà sincère quelqu'un qui a des
convictions et combative
je crois que c'est une bonne présidente
au co présidente de groupes écologistes
la décrirais pas parce que franchement
je n'ai pas beaucoup d'atomes crochus
avec la prétention réaction j'entends
excessive travailleuses bonne élève
qu'est ce que vous préférez parmi tous
ces qualificatifs offrit un peu de vrai
dans tout ça je suis quelqu'un qui a des
convictions et c'est vrai que parfois on
se laisse emporter par l'enthousiasmé
parfois aussi en se disant minces les
choses n'avancent pas assez vite
après je pense que si je suis aussi
quelqu'un de compromis et c'est
important en politique de savoir passer
des compromis parce que le jusqu'au
boutisme ça ne mène nulle part alors
barbara pour glee c'est parti pour une
semaine très politique qui commence sur
fond d'élection lundi marquée par la
victoire du fn à brignoles son candidat
laurent lopez a battu l'ump catherine
d'heure avec mille voix d'avancé appels
au front républicain n'a visiblement pas
fonctionné pour cette cantonale
partielle pierre lascars et charleville
à neuf étaient sur place
la candidate ump s'est voulue jusqu'au
bout confiante et sûr de l'efficacité du
front républicain
j'attends la proclamation un combat
n'est jamais perdu jusqu'à la dernière
seconde
mais le faire
lopez un peu avant 20 heures les
résultats tombent
avec plus de 53% c'est une victoire sans
appel du candidat fn laurent lopez
ça montre les gens se sont réveillés
symbolisant des couteaux l'ump ça montre
le système est tombé ce soit mais pour
laurent lopez pas question de voir dans
le score de dimanche
un aboutissement mais plutôt une
promesse d'autres victoires lors de
futurs scrutins
est ce qu'il y aura un avant après
écoute et j'espère sincèrement que
brignoles nord qu'europe tête au début
de la reconquête notre pays voilà et ça
a manifesté l'espoir pour tous ceux qui
souffrent soit français quelques ténors
frontiste avait fait le déplacement
l'occasion d'annoncer la mort du conte
républicain
la province à lyon même si le score est
impressionnant il reste toutefois à
relativiser le fn a certes gagné hier
soir son deuxième conseiller général
mais le maillage du territoire par un
tissu du logo bleu marine reste encore
loin
barbara bon pili ce résultat de
brignoles pour vous c'est avant tout une
victoire du fn ou une défaite du front
républicain
je crois que c'est c'est une défaite des
partis républicains en général qui se
retrouve à devoir gérer une situation
dans laquelle on voit bien qu'il ya un
lien qui s'est coupé avec les gens et
moi ce qui m'inquiète beaucoup c'est
quand je vois les réactions
depuis cette élection que ce soit à
gauche comme à droite où on a tendance à
se renvoyer dos à dos à ce sens voyez
les invectives les uns les autres
je ne vois pas en quoi ces réactions
politiciennes devons améliorer la
situation
donc moi politique aussi vous avez bien
entendu vous avez bien entendu aussi ce
qu'a dit le parti socialiste si nous
parti socialiste nous ne sommes pas au
deuxième tour c'est à cause de nos amis
est à cause du fait que vous les verts
il est parti en solitaire mais on les
écologistes sont évidemment responsable
de tout ce qui se passe de manière dans
ce pays nos responsables alors je pense
que on a une responsabilité collective
et qu' il va falloir qu'on se pose les
bonnes questions là l'avancé des
extrêmes a toujours existé en période de
crise on est en période de crise donc il
ya déjà cet élément là à prendre en
compte
face à cette période de crise qu'est ce
que nous proposons comme réponse et
c'est là où est le problème
là les réponses proposées par le
gouvernement ça ne va pas assez vite
il ya aussi une attente absolue et là on
sent que le gouvernement ne répond pas
suffisamment vite aux attentes des gens
donc ça c'est le premier problème et
l'opposition
en face est tellement dans ces batailles
internes ces batailles de leadership au
plus tôt fin août mais que les gens se
disent mais l'opposition n'apporte rien
non plus comme proposition pour régler
nos problèmes ils sont centrés sur leurs
problèmes et ils ne regardent pas nos
problèmes
résultat évidemment ça attise les
mécontentements et les voies vont vers
le front national
côté la nes tension jusqu'à tension je
vous propose d'écouter l'année
du premier ministre jean marc ayrault
après ce résultat
la responsabilité des dirigeants de
l'ump qui n'ont même pas levé le petit
doigt pour défendre leur candidate est
extrêmement importante
il faut pas qu'il s'étonne ainsi qu'une
partie de leurs électeurs les fuit pour
aller directement vers ce parti c'est ce
que vous disiez l'ump et le ps qui se
renvoient dos à dos voilà ça peut pas
continuer comme ça jusqu'aux élections
municipales non non je vraiment moi je
fais un appel à tous les politiques pour
que le niveau remonte pour que les gens
que moi je vois dans ma permanence
quelqu'un dit je te les déconnecter du
terrain il faudrait qu'on nous suivent
un peu sur le terrain pour comprendre
qu'au contraire on voit ce qui se passe
il ce qu'on voit c'est que les gens
disent vous ne vous intéressez pas à
nous on se sent abandonnés vous sentez
cette démobilisation de la gauche
notamment sur le terrain cc c'est plutôt
un sentiment la gauche donne un
sentiment d'impuissance et c'est vrai
que les atermoiements des politiques qui
sont menées
c'est à dire on avance on recule on
hésite c'est très mauvais parce que du
coup les gens se disent à tort
d'ailleurs mais se disent il n'y a pas
de cap
et ça c'est pas rassurant et quand on
est dans une période de crise quand on
voit les usines qui ferment cetera on a
besoin d'avoir des gens qui donne un cap
le front national donne un très mauvais
cap mais il en donne un dame aux
barbares billy puisque ce que j'entends
c'est une vraie critique du gouvernement
une vraie critique aussi de la ligne
suivie par le prieur de la république
non c'est 6 km de la ligne
une crétine de la communication autour
de la ligne et c'est une critique aussi
on en parlera peut-être mais
effectivement de certains atermoiements
notamment sur le budget d'irlande eire
et voilà notamment sur le budget qui
font que enfin vraiment on a
l'impression qu'il n'y a pas de ligne
alors que encore une fois ce ce n'est
pas le cas mais certes est certes un
élément de communication font que les
gens croient que
navigue à vue alors on va en parler mais
en attendant une autre ville est sous
les feux de l'actualité marseille où a
lieu la primaire socialiste la sénatrice
samia ghali a créé la surprise en se
qualifiant pour le second tour tout
comme patrick mennucci la ministre marie
arlette carlotti a été éliminé un
scrutin sur fond de soupçons et
d'accusations à débat pour le moins
tendu entre deux tours entre patrick
mennucci sa magali je vous propose
évidemment de regarder cet extrait qu'on
va commenter ensemble
patrick mennucci a le soutien des élus
manger il soutient des marseillais
finalement ceux qui l'auront expliqué
pendant des mois et des mois qu'ils
étaient nés les systèmes anti magouilles
anti discussion entre amis et c'est ce
qu'ils entendent elle est pratiquée
aujourd'hui
moi je n'ai rien demandé à personne je
n'ai fait aucun arrangement et personne
je n'ai absolument rien promis à
personne les jeunes font de singles et
d'ailleurs est d'ailleurs écoutent ils
vont bien large du rocher l'interrompt
l'après midi là parce que je ne serai
l'a reconnu il a reconnu aux jeunes
qu'il a eu et tu es toi-même et toi-même
patrick tu as dié au ils ont promis un
poste de sénateur comme les communistes
se situe à 10 à patrick chiche drogba
avec l'indien père patrick je regrette
vraiment que tu as baisse l'autre débat
envoyé pour le climat voire oubliés on
va s'intéresser aux primaires massaise
aux primaires en général c'est le tous
de l'hebdo commentés notamment ce rôle
des primaires dans la vie politique
denis jeambar notre éditorialiste nous a
rejoint bonjour de nos jours alors
justement ces primaires vous l'avez vu
cet extrait c'est assez significatif
s'est jamais un long fleuve tranquille
oui mais celle du parti socialiste
pendant l'élection présidentielle
n'avait pas été non plus un long fleuve
tranquille il faut s'en souvenir
il y avait eu des phrases assez rude qui
avaient été prononcées notamment contre
françois hollande je vous rappelle quand
par martine aubry
quand il ya du flou il ya un loup
c'était pas une phrase plus que ça ces
primaires moi je crois je crois que les
primaires c'est un progrès de la
démocratie et c'est un moyen aussi
d'établir une fluidité entre les parties
les militants mais aussi les
sympathisants et les français en général
donc je trouve que globalement c'est un
progrès démocratique et que ça sera
irréversible dans notre vie politique et
que voilà jeu c'est une très grande
nouveauté dont on mesure peut-être pas
toutes les conséquences ça va pas sans
débat chaotique mais la politique c'est
aussi le débat le débat chaotique
chevaux si vous avez connu ça à nicolas
hulot et eva joly
oui oui non je suis d'accord avec vous
globalement je pense que les primaires
sont plutôt une avancée parce que ça
permet aussi à des gens qui ne sont pas
investis dans les partis politiques de
venir donner un avis et faire avancer le
débat en plus ça permet aussi de parler
un peu de fond puisque on est dans des
prix dans des primaires sur des gens qui
sont normalement du même bord politique
donc c'est intéressant et moi j'étais
même assez favorable dans pour les
municipales dans certaines villes où une
figure ne s'imposait pas
particulièrement de faire des primaires
pour à toute la gaule par exemple des
primaires ouvertes sur toute la gauche
ça peut ça peut s'entendre dans
certaines villes ça pouvait s'entendre
annonça pouvez vous pouvez même
s'entendre à amiens où je suis élu denis
jeambar on al'impression on a vu qu'en
mai un débat assez cacophonique on a
l'impression qu'il faut vraiment être à
marseille marseillais pour pour
comprendre quelque chose à savoir il
faut quand même rappeler rappeler le nom
de participants à la primaire au premier
tour il ya quand même eu vingt mille
personnes est un moment de la
présidentielle il y avait eu 27 mille
personnes à marseille donc sur une
élection comme ça ça mobilise quand même
beaucoup de monde
même si on les amène en bus et en
voiture c'est quand même beaucoup de
monde qui se déplace et qui s'intéresse
donc il ya un vrai intérêt
ensuite ma la politique c'est ça aussi
et on voit bien qu'il ya deux stratégies
différentes sur marseille délire
considérable et finalement il se
réconcilieront après l'élection vous
savez on en a tellement vu c'est ça
aussi le débat politique on s'affronte
on se confronte et après on se retrouve
cela laisse parfois des traces mais pas
tant que ça justement ça laisse des
traces nicolas hulot eva joly on en
parlait tout à l'heure la cie les
réconcilier c'est pas c'est pas
irréconciliable nicolas hulot a mal vécu
ce qui est arrivé est aussi le fait que
nous justement on avait une primaire
ouverte mais où finalement peut-être
qu'on n'a pas réussi à attirer
suffisamment de monde sur ces primaires
parce qu'on n'est pas un peu un aussi
gros party que ça on n'a peut-être pas
aussi en termes de délais réussi à faire
comme il fallait
c'est un début dans les primaires
métropole c'est pas évident mais en ce
qui concerne marseille je pense qu'il ya
aussi un arrière
il ya quand même lourd passé politique à
marseille a quand même le système
guérini qui perdure qui a qui n'a jamais
été vraiment solide et c'est moi qu'on
puisse dire puisque monsieur limite donc
sa détention ça crée des tensions
et on voit bien que là ce qui est en
train de ressortir c'est toutes ces
tensions là quelque part est ce que
c'est pas plutôt une bonne chose que
finalement on purge un peu tout ça je
pensais plutôt une bonne chose et c'est
que les arbitres soient les marseillais
plutôt que de l'inter je pense que c'est
une très bonne chose
cela dit je rappelle que sur marseille
aussi d'autres possibilités heures voilà
on peut aussi faire une respiration
politique en votant pour karim zéribi
qui est issue qui lui aussi issu des
quartiers marseillais et qui a beaucoup
de choses à proposer
moi je trouve que ça aussi
d'intéressants alors s'il ya une
confrontation mais il ya aussi le choix
de lignes politiques qui s'affrontent et
on voit bien meilleur que magali et là
elle joue les marseillais contre paris
mais ça c'est une tradition il ya une
identité il ya un ads haye et marseille
opposés à paris ça je crois qu'elle est
là
l'a compris c'est ce qui peut réserver
une surprise car d'ailleurs nourri la
surprise du premier tour et qui peut se
retrouver
au second tour merci beaucoup vu ni
merci donné alors on passe à mardi avec
le coup d'envoi d'un débat marathon
c'est un moment fort de la vie
parlementaire les députés ont entamé
l'examen du projet de loi de finances
pour 2014 ils ont commencé par les
recettes c'est-à-dire les impôts les
grandes lignes de ce texte avec elisa
bertolo mais pas de pause fiscale en
2014 le projet de loi de finances
comporte bien 3 milliards d'euros de
prélèvements supplémentaires
c'est essentiellement sur les ménages
que va porter cet effort via une baisse
du quotient familial ou le maintien du
taux réduit de tva à 5,5 pour cent
le gouvernement parle de quasi
stabilisation des impôts mais un
sentiment de ras-le-bol fiscale persiste
pour adoucir ses hausses de prélèvements
en commission des finances la semaine
dernière les députés ont voté quelques
aménagements par exemple l' avantage
fiscal pour les parents d'enfants
scolarisés dans le secondaire et le
supérieur est maintenu les entreprises
seront mieux lotis
la montée en puissance du crédit d'impôt
compétitivité et emploi restituera 10
milliards d'euros aux entreprises via
une baisse du coût du travail
la taxe sur l'excédent brut
d'exploitation ne verra pas le jour
elle sera remplacée par une surtaxe de
l'impôt sur les sociétés
la taxe à 75% fait son grand retour dans
ce projet de loi de finances elle sera
acquittée par les entreprises et non par
les ménages pour les salaires supérieurs
à 1 million d'euros
mais l'essentiel du budget porte sur des
économies le gouvernement doit réduire
les dépenses de 15 milliards d'euros
pour ramener le déficit à 3 6% du pib
l'objectif fixé par bruxelles alors
barbara pomper votre groupe a obtenu les
avancées que vous souhaitiez que vous
demandiez notamment sur la fiscalité
écologique est ce que tu es lequel vous
allez donc le voter ce budget 2014
on va pas on va pas jouer à se faire
peur on a eu on s'est fait peur au début
septembre parce que le budget qui était
annoncé une tenu compte en rien de ce
que nous avions déjà négocié avec le
parti socialiste donc
là on a été obligé de taper du poing sur
la table et vous les avez ces gars
depuis depuis on a obtenu un certain
nombre de progrès qui sont significatifs
notamment la tva baissé pour la
rénovation thermique des bâtiments qui
va vraiment relancer un secteur qui en a
besoin et en plus dans le sens du
développement durable donc c'est
vraiment une fraiseuse non c'est pas
suffisant on a réussi aussi à obtenir
notamment des baisses de commandes il ya
un début de fiscalité qui s'appuie plus
sur la pollution et moins sur les
salaires ce qu'on demande depuis très
longtemps de réorienter la fiscalité et
qu'elle pèse moins sur les salaires et
puis on a réussi aussi à obtenir des
exonérations des deux des suppressions
d'exonérations par exemple sur les
engrais les engrais qu'elle est un
avantage alors qu'ils étaient deux
questions très précises pour avoir
justement pour bénéficier de cette tva
sur la rénovation thermique
il a fallu ne pas augmenter la tva sur
les produits de première nécessité
devait passer à 5 % le reste à 5 5
c'est quand même il ya une contradiction
pour ceux qui ont donc besoin pour le
peuple on n'était pas d'accord on a voté
contre 1 d'ailleurs le fait de rester à
5,5 ne pense qu'il fallait
à partir du moment où s'était contenté
lui a d'autre moyen de financer de
financer ça par exemple il faudrait
s'occuper du crédit impôt recherche qui
pose de vrais problèmes d'optimisation
fiscale sthers est devenue une aubaine
pour certaines entreprises alors que
c'est pas ça l'objectif l'objectif c'est
de développer évidemment la recherche et
le développement qui sont très
importants pour avancer vers
l'investissement et puis vers vers le
l'orientation vers d'autres modes de
production mais ça on peut le faire en
ayant un crédit impôt recherche
un peu plus calibré parce que pour
l'instant l'amiante il calibre et on
perd beaucoup d'argent il ya beaucoup
d'effets d'aubaine
et s'il fallait pas y toucher moi
j'aurais préféré qu'on n'y touche pas
mais a maintenant 5 5,5 attention on
n'est pas non plus sur une énorme
différence c'est moi je trouve que c'est
typiquement ce que je vous disais tout à
l'heure il ya un problème à bercy et là
moi je le dis au gouvernement il y a un
problème à bercy qui balance comme ça
des idées problème exactement moi
vraiment je pense que ce sont les
services de bercy
les services de bercy mais non parce que
les ministres on leur propose plein de
choses
il administre pas être spécialiste de
tout maintenant je pense que les
ministres doivent avoir une ligne que
bercy doit servir cette ligne le fait qu
on me balance comme ça des annonces
qu'on retire après c'est pas y en ait le
plein je pense à nos b e par exemple je
pense aussi à ça ça donne cette
impression dont je vous parlais tout à
l'heure dans une espèce de naviguer à
vue et qui est très préjudiciable sur
tout le monde donc quand on annonce
quelque chose on s'y tient
et là le problème c'est que l'on fait un
pas en avant un pas en arrière un
patient côté ce n'est plus possible et
sur cette affaire de budget ça pose des
problèmes qui n'a rien à voir avec le
budget mais peut-être un petit peu
autres qu'avec l'économie
vous allez me dire c'est préjudiciable
ou pas cette nuit chez lui à un accord
entre edf et areva pour la vente de 2 p
r aux anglais donc le nucléaire encore
du nucléaire toujours du nucléaire vous
étiez contre il ya un coup de canif dans
le contrat
non là nous nous serons nous ce qu'on
veut c'est baisser la part du nucléaire
dans l'électricité consommée en france
donc pour elle a passé de 75 à 50%
est ce qu'on demande au gouvernement
c'est que dans la loi de sur la
transition énergétique qui va arriver à
au printemps prochain que la trajectoire
pour arriver à cet objectif soit
expliqué soit épi soit soit montrée dans
le temps qu'on ait un calendrier et c
est une méthode parce que pour l'instant
c'est un peu flou et c'est vrai que on
avance on avance et il faut qu' il faut
que ce soit plus précis que ça alors on
va parler également de la réforme des
retraites que les députés ont adopté
voté en première lecture et de justesse
270 pour 249 contre et 40 9 abstentions
il faudra travailler plus longtemps
les salariés devront payer plus au titre
des cotisations vieillesse et les
retraités paieront davantage aux six
premières réformes d'un gouvernement de
gauche
barbara pompe il est pourtant les verts
se sont abstenus pourquoi oui on sait ça
a été douloureux pour nous parce que
c'est vrai que c'est on considère que
c'est une occasion manquée cette réforme
des retraites
il fallait remettre à plat le système
qui est un vieux système qui est basé
sur une économie et sur une période
historique qui n'a plus du tout rien à
voir avec ce que c'est ce qui existe
maintenant
donc on c'est une occasion manquée
maintenant après il faut regarder le
texte tel qu'il est on a manqué pour que
vous votiez cette réforme il y avait
quelque chose en trop c'est à dire qu'
il y avait l'allongement de la durée des
cotisations
cet allongement de la durée des
cotisations qui est complètement
incompréhensible dans la mesure où on
sait que maintenant les gens à partir de
55 ans a énormément qui ne travaillent
plus qui sochaux sans vraiment le choix
cotiser on est sur un système absurde en
plus qui va qui va certainement être
revu puisque la mise en oeuvre est
prévue pour l'an très longtemps je pense
que faire ça ça montrait qu'on n'avait
pas voulu toucher au système et qui ont
trouvé une solution qui était très
mauvaise
donc nous on ne pouvait pas voter rien
qu'à cause de ça il ya d'autres éléments
mais l'allongement de la durée de
cotisation n'était pas possible et la
majorité socialiste quand vous vous
abstenez sur les retraites ça les embête
ça les embête cela dit on n'a pas voté
contre non plus même si on aurait pu se
poser mais attention c'est pas m
parce qu'il ya quand même quelques
avancées moi j'essaye j'essaye de ne pas
tomber dans la caricature
donc j'essaye de dire les choses sur la
pénibilité il ya un vrai changement
d'état d'esprit
ça va toucher beaucoup de monde vivant à
faire en europe que c'est une première
c'est une première en europe et il faut
le saluer c'est pour ça que nous on ne
voulait pas voté contre parce qu'on ne
voulait pas on voulait montrer qu'on
salué cet effort là mais le problème du
financement des retraites n'est pas
résolu et les solutions qui ont été
trouvées ne sont pas bonnes
puisqu'on parle d'avenir la france vous
le savez peut-être veut accueillir
l'exposition universelle de 2025 à
présentera sa candidature
deux parlementaires soutiennent ce
dossier les explications de julie eu
l'un des trottoirs roulants
une première ligne de métro un petit et
un grand palais 50 millions de visiteurs
nous sommes en 1900 paris accueille
l'exposition universelle
un événement qui n'a pas été réédité
depuis et si la france déposé sa
candidature pour 2025
une idée lancée il ya deux ans par le
député maire de neuilly-sur-seine
jean-christophe fromantin
la france a besoin peut être aujourd'hui
plus que jamais de retrouver un élan de
se remobiliser de de se recréer un
rassemblement l'idée c'est de d'avoir un
territoire de projets qu'ils soient
nouveaux mais paris a été le territoire
de projets des expos du 19e siècle le
grand paris doit être le territoire de
projets des expos du 21e siècle et le
grand paris articulé avec ces métropoles
avec les grandes métropoles françaises
le concept ray employés de façon
éphémère les infrastructures du futur
grand paris et les monuments existants
des grandes villes françaises
la tour eiffel relooké par les chinois
versailles réinventé par le brésil
chaque exposant se verrait attribuer un
lieu pour une performance qui devrait
faire appel aux nouvelles technologies
là où quelques-uns qui nous écouterait
se dire avec qu'est ce que c'est que
cette lubie de finalement deux élus
locaux lé maire de neuilly et
d'alfortville qui auraient envie
d'initier ce projet ce qu'il n'y a pas
mieux à faire moment on parle de crise
de compétitivité de chômage est bien au
contraire
ce projet ne peut être que fédérateur un
fédérateur économique un booster
d'aménagement du territoire
l'association expo france 2025 créé pour
soutenir cette candidature s'est déjà
attiré le soutien de grands acteurs
économiques politiques et universitaires
objectif être prêt pour le dépôt des
candidatures en 2016
la boue qui entendait beaucoup de choses
sur le terrain vous entendez c'est la
crise on peut rien faire voilà un projet
qui bouge qui parle d'avenir
aulas je pense que les gens damien se
contrefoutent de ce projet pour hitler
mais après je me relâche je découvre
parce que j'étais pas au courant de
cette de cette candidature là si ça peut
permettre de montrer vers où on veut
aller si ça peut permettre de donner des
perspectives de voir quel monde on veut
avoir demain pourquoi pas le problème
c'est un petit peu des séminaires
gouvernementaux crise qu'est ce qu'on
fera en 2020 oui mais après le problème
c'est que ce genre de chose en général
c'est plutôt pour montrer comme on est
beaux par rapport aux autres c'est c'est
souvent la promotion du gigantisme c'est
souvent la promotion des grands
champions de montrer aux qui est enfin
voilà des rapports aussi quand même ça
dépend comment c'est fait il me semble
que là l'exposition universelle on avait
aussi exposé des indigènes de manière
pas très respectueuse des droits de
l'homme à l'époque donc je pense que
tout ça il faut faire attention si c'est
quelque chose qui est tourné vers le
monde qui est tourné vers la coopération
qui est tourné vers l'entrée des verts
des valeurs humanistes
ça peut pourquoi pas être intéressant
après dépenser des sommes folles pour
une opération malgré tout de
communication attention dans la période
il faut faire des copies alors on va
revenir au coeur de l'actualité avec
mercredi une affaire à la une qui
suscite l'indignation à gauche
léonard da 15 ans kosovars interpellées
pendant une sortie scolaire expulsé vers
son pays cela s'est passé le 9 octobre
dernier dans le doubs depuis l' affaire
provoque une tempête au sein de la
gauche
le ministre de l'intérieur est mis en
cause radicale tout a commencé à la
sortie du conseil des ministres
en l'absence de manuel valls en
déplacement vincent peillon a dû
répondre aux questions sur les
conditions d'expulsion de léonard da une
kosovare de 15 ans reconduite à la
frontière lors d'une sortie scolaire une
sortie scolaire
c'est de la scolarité est notre règle
c'est qu'on intervienne pas lorsqu'il ya
scolarité je demande donc on sanctuarise
l'école on garde nos principes de droit
et nos principes d'humanité à l'avenir
parti socialiste c'est l' indignation
après les propos de manuel valls sur
l'impossible l'intégration des roms
l'expulsion des eaux narda scolarisé
depuis cinq ans en france provoquent un
tollé
qu'on soit dans la majorité ou dans
l'opposition il ya des lignes rouges à
ne pas dépasser
or on a dépassé la ligne rouge c'est pas
une expulsion c'est une rafle aller
chercher un enfant dans son école et sa
la gauche ne peut pas signer ce type
d'acte donc c'est inacceptable
leonardo était scolarisée la famille de
léonard da est présente en france depuis
donc la famille de la menara était à 8
semaines de satisfaire aux critères de
la circulaire de régularisation de
novembre dernier il ya quelques années
quand ça arrive et quand nous étions
dans l'opposition on était ému et
souvent indignée et il n'y a pas de
raison que on n'est pas les mêmes
sentiments quand ça arrive aujourd'hui
le clivage est nette du côté de l'ump on
soutient manuel valls ministre favoris
de la droite peut pas critiquer
l'intérieur sur une expulsion
il applique les lois de la république et
on commence à jouer à chaque fois en dix
ans mais elle était là depuis un certain
temps ce que je peux comprendre à ce
moment là il ya plus de règle dans
l'après-midi la polémique continue
d'enfler et s'invite aux questions au
gouvernement
est ce que pour colmater l'explosion de
votre majorité
vous allez sacrifier un préfet de la
république qui n'a fait qu'une chose son
travail en fonction des résultats de
cette enquête monsieur le président
tandja comme je prendrai toutes les
responsabilités qui ceint qui
s'imposeront le moment venu et s'il ya
eu faute
l'arrêté de reconduite à la frontière
sera annulée cette famille reviendra
pour que sa situation soit examinée
réexaminer en fonction de notre droit de
nos principes et de nos valeurs
l'enquêté administrative ouverte par le
ministère de l'intérieur rendra ses
conclusions dans 48 heures alors la
sphère est loin d'être terminée
puisqu'on a appris que le père avait
menti sur les origines kosovarde de sa
famille bref rien n'est encore clair
dans cette affaire il ya une enquête en
cours
quelle est votre position certains
demandent des sanctions et notamment
jusqu'à la démission de manuel valls
c'est ce que vous demandez vous si non
alors moi je vois que on est en train de
faire encore de la politique
politicienne sur des sujets qui sont des
sujets graves
donc moi j'essaye de regarder plutôt le
fond de la sphère le fond c'est que on a
des règles sur la politique
d'immigration qui à mon avis sont plus
très adapté et de toute façon quelles
que soient les résultats de l' enquête
administrative qu'il y ait eu ou non une
faute on voit que ça c' est la manière
dont ça s'est passé ça nous interpelle
tous ça nous interpelle tous parce qu on
est dans de l'humain on est dans de
l'alu de choc c'est plus les conditions
de l'interpellation de la jeunesse qui
vous est ce qui me choque c'est que
c'est que manifestement on n'est plus
dans un traitement humain des choses et
ne jamais oublier et ça c'est la ferme
au nasdaq il a peut être montré
mais on en a tous dans nos
circonscriptions moi j'ai une lycéenne
qui s'appelle nan et qui est dans la
situation dans la même situation et
d'ailleurs qui reçoit un soutien de tous
les lycéens qui sont avec elle donc on
est face à des affaires humaines et donc
qu'il ne faut jamais les traiter comme
des affaires de chiffres il faut les
traiter comme affaires humaines après
qu'il faille des règles je l'entends est
ce qu'elles sont encore adapté
c'est avoir plus d'ailleurs peut-être
peut-être ne fait que le fait que pour
demander une régularisation des
personnes soient obligés de payer 50
euros
je peux vous dire que rien que ça ça
pose un problème parce que des gens du
coup qu'ils n'ont pas faim en général
cumul ça c'est à dire que ce sont des
gens qui sont d'une extrême pauvreté ne
peuvent pas sortir comme ça 50 euros
donc on voit bien que on a des règles à
revoir mais surtout ne jamais oublier
que c'est que c'est toute la misère la
misère qui s'exprime dans ces personnes
là qui sont aux anges et qui cumule
général généralement 3 forcément du
ministre de l'intérieur
oui ou non gg parce qu'il est remis en
cause f qu'il a bafoué les valeurs de
gauche
comment les cépages et j'ai pas envie
d'en parler dans la mesure où tout le
monde sait ce qu'on pense parce qu'il ya
eu la sphère des roms avant parce que on
voit bien que on est en train de déraper
parce que peut-être qu'on oublie encore
une fois qu'on est face à nous
mais moi je ne jeûne je ne veux pas je
on est en train de crever de la
politique politicienne
on est en train de crever des affaires
des dessins et des autres moi je pense
que manuel valls devrait se poser de
vraies questions sur la manière dont il
traite ses dossiers
après je ne veux pas hurler avec les
loups
parce que je veux qu'on reste sur les
fonds d affaires est ce que vous pensez
pas justement donc que c'est à l'elysée
ou matignon en tout cas de reprendre en
main le dossier pour rédigés
éventuellement une nouvelle circulaire
clair et net et bien franchement donnait
pas franchement que comme en tire des
leçons qu'on en tire des leçons pour que
ce ne soit plus possible pour que des
enfants qui sont scolarisés puisse
continuer à être scolarisés
oui il faut le faire il faut le faire
après le président le premier ministre
moi je ne donne d'injonctions à personne
je dis simplement que là on est face à
un vrai problème est qu'il faut trouver
des solutions et qui évidemment en
attendant d'avoir trouvé des solutions
cette famille a été traité de manière
scandaleuse donc leonarda puisse revenir
et qu'elle puisse en attendant que cette
affaire soit géré qu'elle puisse
reprendre ses études parce que pendant
ce temps là est en train de perdre des
heures de cours est en train de bloquer
l'école dans ce moment ou pas écoutez
c'est le côté positif de cette affaire
c'est qu'on est en train de tellement de
parler de la montée du front national
la montée des égoïsmes de la montre et
de la montée de l'individualisme et puis
du rejet de l'autre
les lycéens nous donne une belle leçon
jeudi il le faisait à amiens bien avant
la sphère leonarda ils le font là il
nous donne une belle leçon de
citoyenneté d'humanisme et moi ça m'a
fait chaud au coeur de voir qu'ils
pouvaient descendre dans la rue par
solidarité je trouve que c'est une belle
image est évidemment que je soutiens le
mouvement
alors on va passer au jeudi si vous le
voulez bien l'ump fait son inventaire en
tout cas ou presque
la réunion au siège parisien de l'ump
être bien eu lieu mais pas l'inventaire
du quinquennat de nicolas sarkozy
puisque la quasi-totalité des têtes
d'affiché du parti manquait à l'appel le
président de l'ump lui étaient bien
présents il a dit veiller au
rassemblement écouter il ne s'agit pas
non plus de régler je ne sais quel
compte personnel ni avec nicolas sarkozy
ni avec françois fillon
d'abord parce que l'auto flagellation ça
ne fait jamais avancer les choses et
ensuite parce que moi je n'accepte pas
que certains fassent de la question du
bilan une occasion de je ne sais quel
règlement de comptes
je demande simplement qu'ils ne viennent
pas alors dire après au fil d'interviews
ou de discours ce qu'ils n'ont pas voulu
dire aujourd'hui les yeux dans les yeux
aux militants et sympathisants de notre
famille politique
alors le bilan du mps j'imagine que
c'est pas vraiment votre tasse de thé
c'est pas forcément votre parti mais moi
j'ai une question très très très simple
si si si si d'accord mais alors écoulés
et j'avais bien envie d'entendre votre
avis après je vous poserai autre
question non parce que on en revient au
problème qu'on a vu tout à l'heure c'est
que on est face à une montée des
extrêmes
pourquoi parce que on n'est pas capable
de proposer des alternatives aux gens et
le rôle de l'opposition démocratique
c'est de proposer des alternatives et
quand on a des problèmes au niveau du
gouvernement certainement mais quand on
a une opposition qui est incapable
justement de faire ce travail de bilan
et de perspectives politiques
eh bien on est face à un vrai problème
démocratique
donc moi je suis concerné par ce qui se
passe à l'ump en tant que démocrate
parce que j'ai besoin moi de voir une
opposition qui n'est pas dans la
facilité mais qui est
dans la réflexion de fond il semble qu
est-ce que vous quand vous étiez dans
l'opposition vous aviez accepté aussi de
faire ce travail d'inventaire de
d'essayer de de définir ce que peut être
ce que peut être l'avenir votre position
de tête a écouté personne n'est parfait
mais en tout cas on a essayé de faire le
travail
on est on a essayé de faire le travail
et on a essayé justement de proposer une
réelle alternative est ce qu'on nous on
continue de faire en tant que partenaire
de la majorité de continuer de dire au
ps attention là vous partez par là je
pense qu'il vaudrait mieux s'orienter un
petit peu plus de la majorité douceur
mais oui mais on est là pour ça on est
là pour dire aussi comme comme rôle ça
non pas si simple parce que d'un côté on
nous traite de collabo parce qu on est
avec le parti socialiste qui ne fait pas
assez ce qui devrait faire selon selon
on nous dit et puis de l'autre côté
voilà donc non non on est on est dans
une position qui n'est pas si
confortable que ça mais on pense qu'on
doit apporter notre pierre et on pense
qu on a des propositions à faire
là on le voit sur la conversion
écologique de l'économie qui va créer
des centaines de milliers d'emplois on
est dans une période de crise on grâce à
cette conversion va créer des centaines
de milliers d'emplois mais je pense que
se mobilisent et se battre pour ça c'est
tout à notre honneur vraiment tout autre
sujet soulevé bien là aussi on va aller
sur un rapport qui a été établi au sénat
sur la prostitution il aide les
personnes concernées à s'en sortir le
détail avec nathalie d'ivoire voilà d un
exemple de petites cartes que nous
donnons aux personnes que nous
rencontrons sur les lieux de
prostitution
une adresse un numéro de téléphone en
cas de détresse mais aussi des
plaquettes d'information à l'amicale du
nid on va sur le terrain pour aider les
personnes prostituées à s'en sortir et
leur proposer un accompagnement
personnalisé protections sociales minima
sociaux réinsertion professionnelle ces
démarches peuvent être difficiles à
réaliser quand on a un passé de
prostituées l'ouverture des droits et
complexe quand il s'agit en particulier
de dhr à la formation et à l'emploi
l'accompagnement vers la formation à
l'emploi
nécessite un travail avec les
institutions au syndicat des
travailleurs du sexe on considère au
contraire la prostitution comme un
métier normal on constate des
discriminations au quotidien accédez à
des droits bancaire le fait pouvoir même
ouvrir un compte ou le droit l'assurance
eu droit à l'emprunt il lit peut avoir
des fortes discriminations
le fait d'être à 9,7 ya plein de vin
plein de d'administration qui trouve
cinq qui sont assez sceptiques ou qui
sont qui n'ont pas forcément envie de
deux drones les services qui sont qui
sont disponibles pour les sénateurs les
prostituées sont d'abord des victimes
dans leur rapport jean pierre godefroy
et chantal jouanno veulent changer de
regard sur la prostitution
il faut faire jouer une présomption de
victime pour pouvoir une personne
prostituée et donc il faut l'aider à
sortir de la prostitution il faut
l'aider à dénoncer son réseau donc il ya
beaucoup de dispositions qu'on préconise
comme l'octroi d'un titre de séjour
comme une allocation temporaire de
l'accès au logement d'urgence un vrai
système de protection de la part de
l'état selon les sénateurs et diarra
1000 à 40000 personnes prostituées en
france dont la grande majorité est
d'esclaves de réseaux de traite
dans ce rapport il ya beaucoup de
mesures pour accompagner les personnes
qui se prostituent mais pas de mesures
de contrainte
l'arsenal législatif est absent vous le
regrettez ça oui alors c'est une
situation très délicate à la question
des prostituées parce qu'il ya d'un côté
la question de l'esclavagisme de la
traite d'êtres humains qui est un sujet
très grave
après il ya la question de la
prostitution en soi et là on voit bien
que les opinions divergent entre ceux
qui considèrent que c'est un travail
d'autres qui considère que de toute
façon vendre son corps c'est ce n'est
pas possible et donc moi je moi je
la position que nous on a et qui quelque
part recouvre les deux c'est que d'abord
un il faut absolument abolir le délit de
racolage passif qui les met dans des
situations très délicates parce que ce
qu'elle devienne pas du tout des
victimes mais là elles sont punies elle
même et puis là il ya un rapport de mots
d'olivier à l'assemblée nationale qui va
qui donne lieu à une proposition de loi
qui viserait à pénaliser le client
donc en fait à renverser les choses nous
on pense que c'est très dangereux parce
que ça risque de précariser encore plus
les femmes ou les hommes d'ailleurs
prostituées puisqu'il serait encore plus
poussée vers se cacher et à la merci
justement de ses clients qui auraient
peur de se changer la loi et prônent les
deux rapports tout mélanger et refaire
une nouvelle loi offre tout mélanger je
ne sais pas mais en tout cas la question
des personnes prostituées doit sortir
absolument des grandes théories et se
confronter à la réalité de cette
situation et aider celles qui veulent
s'en sortir
celles qui ont envie de faire autre
chose il faut les sortir du système où
elles sont où elle n'existe pas donc il
faut qu'elles existent il faut qu'elle
soit reconnue qu'elle soit aidée
après je pense que si on s'activait
vraiment sur ce qui existe déjà dans la
loi c'est à dire la recherche la lutte
contre les réseaux mafieux qui qui gère
les prostituées je pense qu on
avancerait plus parce que la question
des réseaux pour moi est un est un
problème central bar appropriée on va
terminer cette émission avec des images
de notre dame des landes souvenez-vous
le mouvement a démarré il ya un an
c'est le plus de l'hebdo vous proposait
de suivre un des extraits d'un
documentaire qui s'appelle le tarmac est
dans le pré où l'histoire d'un an de
mobilisation est affrontements entre les
forces de l'ordre et les opposants à
l'aéroport de notre dame des landes où
le tout avant première avec simon
barbarie à une vingtaine de kilomètres
de nantes
des gendarmes suréquipés face à des
paysans en colère et des
alter-mondialistes provocateur voilà
près de 40 ans que le projet du futur
aéroport du grand ouest sur le site de
notre dame des landes divise tournée
l'année dernière le documentaire le
tarmac est dans le pré de thibaut fériés
donne la parole aux protagonistes de
deux visions du monde
un projet inutile ruineux et
anti-écologique pour les porte-drapeaux
de ce que l'on nomme la guerre
y'a bocagères on n'a pas besoin d'aller
loin pour puiser de l'eau ici et les
zones humides et bien on veut contourner
la loi pour faire un aéroport sur une
zone humide magnifique comme ça un
bocage magnifique comme ça c'est
impensable
la loi dit aucune construction sur les
zones humides
sauf si on n'a pas de la preuve qu'on ne
peut pas faire autrement
alors là pour faire autrement on à
nantes atlantique qui existe et qui est
pas saturer une étape essentielle au
développement économique de la région
pour un front uni d'élus locaux il faut
aujourd'hui prendre en compte la
nécessité d'avoir du développement
pourquoi développement parce que le
développement c'est des projets c'est
cette l'emploi c'est de la croissance
ces mots là ce ne sont pas des
abstractions on ne trouve pas d'emploi
s'il n'ya pas projet s'il n'y a pas
d'activité alors que le futur aéroport
du grand ouest devrait voir le jour en
2017 ce documentaire capte les enjeux et
les rouages de la bataille de notre dame
des landes soit une opposition radicale
entre deux modèles de développement et
de croissance
pour un seyant dernier expression
document sud le 4 novembre prochain
une impression d'avoir deux philosophies
on entend dans ce documentaire
évidemment le concret l'économique
contre l'utopie le développement durable
c'est conciliables tout ça l'utopie vous
parler de ceux qui n'ont pas changé
d'avis depuis 40 ans c'est bien cela
dont vous parlez l'aéroport
justement l'aéroport a été décidée il ya
40 ans il ya quarante ans la situation
économique sociale écologique n'avait
rien à voir avec maintenant ces gens
n'ont pas évolué depuis 40 ans il faut
que maintenant il avance et qu'il vienne
aux réalités économiques et écologiques
et les réalités économiques et
écologiques c'est que maintenant on a
moins besoin d'aéroport on s'est rendu
compte que les trans